i'm about to dissect a case of grey's
anatomy but i think i want to do it not
just medically we should do it legally
welcome to the channel legal eagle hey
legal eagles
[Applause]
doctors never mean to screw up crap
crap crap crap crap is the last thing
you want to hear
in a surgical room if i saw a transcript
that said crap crap crap
i mean i would see dollar sign dollar
sign dollar sign it's not like we want
to hurt
anyone but sometimes we do sometimes we
make mistakes
and then the lawyers make it right i'm
sorry
i'm looking for dr torres yes hi great
you've been sued is that how it happens
uh sort of in a medical malpractice
situation like this
uh you obviously have to start the
lawsuit somehow and the way you do that
is called process of service
okay and if you didn't know where the
person was
or where they worked or you didn't know
who their lawyer was
then you would have to hire someone
called the process server to actually
physically hand you is that the person
who throws it at you and says you you
you can't it can't because i've seen
that in movies they they throw it and
it's like oh i got served what does that
mean i mean you need to
have a competent adult who is able to
verify that this is the person
who is being sued so throwing it in a
door that is not best practice okay
ready to build me a new hip he needs to
be able to do
this see right there can a new hip do
that
more importantly will he be doing it by
december he's got olympic qualifiers
coming up you mentioned a crash last
year they said it gave me arthritis you
can't win the gold with arthritis
i want the peterson hip would one hard
crash
cause arthritis for the rest of his
young career it sounds off
the only thing i can imagine is if you
have a significant loss of cartilage
or potentially a labral tear but there's
other procedures that you can go about
from an orthopedic standpoint rather
than just replacing the hip
also what they're asking of the doctors
is not practical at all
to make promises that he's going to be
able to do a move that
promise on recovery time none of this is
ever guaranteed
because in medicine you don't even know
what's going to happen until you open
the patient
up especially in a specific case like
this is hyper-specific
he's not a run-of-the-mill joint
replacement patient it's funny to say
that because one of the first cases you
learn about in law school is called
hawkins versus mcgee
you might have heard of it colloquially
because it's called the hairy hand case
where in the turn of the century a
doctor had a patient
who had a hand condition i think his
hand was burned
and the doctor promised that not only
would he have a fully functional hand
but it would be a hundred percent
recovered okay
and uh he had a skin graft and as a
result he was not given
a 100 normal hand but a hand that was
functional but hairy
and so the lawsuit was can you recover
damages
for the breach of the promise that was
given when he was promised a 100 normal
hand and given a hairy hand
and the answer is yes you have to value
whatever the difference is
in money between a normal hand and a
hairy hand buddy of mine got this one
he was back on the mountain in no time
this is what i need
okay even if i did agree that a hip
replacement is the right course of
treatment
i've never even used the uh peterson
resurfacing hip joint i
doubt you or your team want you to be my
first yes
no experience whatsoever barreling
forward without doing the research and
making specific promises this is
a lot of patients in general treat
medicine as if it's like a shopping
thing
i want the x when in reality sometimes x
isn't what's best for the patient
and sometimes it puts you in this murky
position where the patient feels like
they're not getting what they want
you're not giving it to them because you
think it's not in their best interest
and then they do something like legal
review for you on one of these websites
and as a result
you can't even comment on that because
legally you're breaking patient privacy
if you comment on that
oh i never thought about that that's
absolutely right i'll research the joint
i'll learn what i can i'm not making any
promises i'm not worried i mean despite
the fact that she appears to have been
actually making some promises
it is obviously good that she is going
to do some research here it's not
necessarily dispositive that a doctor
hasn't done a procedure before
and is therefore negligent based on
whatever outcome happens but often
in cases like this at least the
manufacturer has an interest in making
sure that
their own products are installed
correctly so to my knowledge
medical manufacturers will give doctors
extensive training so that things
are done correctly on on the user end
they will send in a rep
during the time of the procedure to be
with us and guide us with the questions
that we may have and they're really well
trained
because a lot of the stuff tech wise
comes out so
soon you just have to have them on the
same page
i'm not settling
okay okay you convinced me okay
i tried then there are things to
remember tomorrow let the jury see your
face
wait tomorrow that's right what how fast
is that
that's ridiculous this is a conversation
that they would be having on
day one on day two on day three this
would be a multi-year process let the
jury see your face you wear a suit dark
not bright skirt not pants minimal
jewelry heels pantyhose
professional but feminine you still have
your wedding ring
yes wear it juries respond better to
married women with families
that's a little misogynistic there i
mean so there is there's a whole
science to presenting yourself in front
of a jury this is going a little bit
crazy in terms of the specifics i mean
you want to dress
nicely there are whole names on the
internet about um
takashi 6969 showing up to court with
like
tattoos all over his face his tai like
down to here and
like his shirt out and stuff so you
don't want to show up to court
looking like that being so specific
about what you're wearing
she's a doctor's colors does it matter
not really maybe on the extreme margins
you ready sure okay okay as someone who
knows a fair bit about men's fashion
what do you notice about the shirt that
this guy is wearing it's
a different color collar and probably
cuffs
yep so he's wearing what's called a
contrast collar and french cuffs yes
which is if i had to choose the most
pretentious thing you could possibly
wear
with a suit i would say contrast colors
now there's nothing wrong with that
you know if uh you know you're a tobacco
tycoon
maybe and you're drinking a mint julep
on a patio contrast colors great i
believe that there's only one
proper color or a shirt which is white
okay but that
it makes shopping a lot easier
[Music]
an above the knee amputation is usually
a more aggressive one if you can you
always try and go below the knee for
stability purposes
also there's a lot of blood vessels here
that are really dangerous so
most patients that i see who have
amputations usually it's like
diabetes complications gangrene
are below the knee amputations it's rare
for me at least in
primary care to see above the knee
amputation i imagine you want to
save something below the knee so that
the prosthesis
is exactly more functional exactly
okay you do rise when the judge comes in
[Music]
what if i could so that is great there's
a whole
science and pseudoscience to making your
client
presentable and human in front of the
jury okay and
you're technically not allowed to talk
to the jury except in
opening statement and closing argument
so anything you can do to humanize
your client the better and notice he's
not wearing a tie
makes sense and he's a young guy uh you
know
humanizes him a little bit but to to
kind of get that jab in and say oh gosh
i can't stand up because of this
horrible thing that the doctor did to me
that's really
driving home the point driving home the
point uh it's not gonna show up on any
transcript anywhere
serving as a juror in a medical
malpractice case isn't easy i don't know
about y'all but
i'm no doctor well i've barely made it
through high school biology
okay fine but you are going to get a
crash
course education in orthopedic medicine
and post-operative infections and you're
going to hear words like
pseudomonas and emboli
don't let that intimidate you so the
sort of aw shucks thing like
i'm not a doctor blah blah blah that can
be good
but you want to pair that with making
the defense
seem like they're the ones that are
trying to overly complicate things
and that you're the speaker of truth
you're going to tell them exactly what
happened because you're not hiding
anything
in an opening statement like this what
you would want to say is you're going to
hear
a lot of medical jargon the the defense
wants you to be confused about these
things
but you want to transition to your theme
the one thing you want the jury to
remember throughout the entire case
the load start that they can hold on to
and you say despite all this complicated
stuff
and we're going to explain it to you the
one thing you need to remember is
this dr torres agreed to perform
a surgery she did not fully understand
we will establish that dr torres made a
series
of faulty decisions eventually costing
mr travis
reed a thriving healthy olympic
athlete his legs
and we will establish that all of this
started because of one
careless mistake so that's not bad it's
a little argumentative
an opening statement is not uh like a
closing argument where you're allowed to
make whatever arguments
you want an opening statement is there
so that you can tell the jury
what is going to happen what evidence is
going to come out based on
extension discovery that you have done
what i don't like about this is that he
has
put the stakes too high this doctor made
one
huge mistake and this doctor did
something she didn't understand
if i was the defense you just disprove
that and he loses exactly
i would say my closing argument i would
say remember when the plaintiff's
attorney said
the doctor didn't understand that well
you heard from the doctor
that she did 100 hours of research
corresponded with the manufacturer and
brought the
manufacturing rep out to participate in
surgery she knew what she was doing
is it true that in medical malpractice
cases
unlike the burden of proof being being
beyond a reasonable doubt it just has to
be more likely than not
that's exactly correct and that is the
case with all civil cases
it's called the preponderance of the
evidence standard all right let's start
closing irrigation please wait the
spongebob is off we're missing one
sponge are you kidding me can't close
until we find it so this is true
uh we do a very careful sponge count
before and after the procedure prior to
closing
because there have been cases as you're
well aware of sponges being left in
patients tools being left in patients in
fact i remember when we were operating
we would have on the wall
all the sponges that we've uh we're
gonna use for that case so there would
be like 30 sponges on the wall in little
pockets yeah almost like the shoe things
right yeah that makes sense and then as
we take them out we put them back in and
we've made certain adjustments where
before we
just use sponges by themselves now they
have an attached plastic ring
that makes them easier to spot you could
also leave that plastic ring outside of
the body so you know to take the sponge
out
so there's been a lot of adjustments to
improve here but clearly it still
happens sometimes
are you saying that dr torres knew she
left a sponge
in mree's body and she didn't care no of
course she cared but
no but still she knowingly left who
who's this on the stand
exactly this is one of the nurses or
doctors
in the hospital so the plaintiff
as apparently his first witness has
called a hostile witness
that is insane juries like all humans
um have the primacy and latency effect
so
they're going to remember what they
heard first and they're going to
remember what they heard last yes
so using that to your advantage at this
point to the sand you would call either
the plaintiff himself to tell the entire
sad story of
what happened to him or you call your
expert
who is going to explain on your side on
your side all of the medical stuff
uh from the secondary material you would
never
call a witness that is basically on the
other side yeah
the patient was running out of time he
would have hun it's a
yes or no question
i got a boy in college good kid and i
went to visit him last month and you
would not believe the sponge i found in
this ink i mean there's no telling ask a
question
objection yes that was irrelevant but
that's like
the fifth most important objection to
make here he's just telling a story i
got this kid in college
he's a real mess he left a sponge in the
sink the only thing you're allowed to do
during examination is ask questions
that's it well let's fast forward to the
next time we saw mr reed
about two weeks later and how was he
then was he
good happy recovering well
he had an infection hi there travis i
hear you got quite the fever attempts
103 i'm just starting his work up he's
burning up and she said this is weeks
later
apparently but weeks later she's just
seeing him for the first time
like she would see him the next day that
sounds negligent i had to force him to
come in
how are you feeling travis scene wait he
went home with a fever
no post-surgical fever can happen and
there's like a thing that we remember in
medical school called the 5ws wind water
walking
wonder drugs um and they all mean
something different like utis pulmonary
embolism is one of them
uh wind being pneumonia medications you
could be taking can cause a fever and
you try and rule things out but the fact
that he went home with the fever and
he's
103 that's a really high fever that
should be thoroughly investigated
is that a murmur okay so they are
listening to that travis
i'm just going to take a look at the
right side
well it's funny when you listen for
heart sounds you actually listen
starting on the right side of the body
and a lot of people patients that are
medically in tuned
from watching shows or have some
curiosity they'll say doctor you know
the heart's on the left side i'm like
well there are uh
blood vessels that come off the heart
that are on the right side that we
listen to as well
uh the pulmonary artery so you wanna
listen there and then move your way and
make your way
aorta listen to the chambers of the
heart so yeah we do listen on the right
side to hear the heart
that looks bad that looks like an
infected wound what does allow me yeah
so
when we give medical feedback when we
listen to a patient's lungs where we
look at wounds
we tend not to exclaim our feelings
so we don't say that sounds scary that's
good that's about it it's either normal
or
abnormal and you keep it at that i don't
want you to worry the wound looks a
little infected
a little in fact okay i mean he looks
like a zombie from my eyes what i'm
seeing right here is
all kinds of reasons why the hospital
could have not only
contributed to the initial negligence
but committed its own malpractice as
well
which is that this patient is being sent
home too early yes this this patient
is not being checked on regularly and to
the extent that they are checking on
this patient they're not examining
the wound where the surgery took place
yeah so
that wound did not get infected today
yeah that's been an infection that's
been festering and generally speaking
after you have surgery you have not only
follow-ups with the surgeon you have
follow-ups with your primary care doctor
all of which times we do vitals we check
the wounds in fact
anytime a patient now is hospitalized we
have one of our nurses call the patient
the next day
to make sure they understand the
medicines they should be taking what
symptoms are they experiencing and if
anything is off they come right back
and what about the murmur could the
infection travel to his heart his vitals
are stable so first we've got to clean
out that joint okay we can't afford any
delays see another thing that's uh
untrue how does she know the wound is
not just infected versus the joint is
infected well at this point they might
as well just paint a dollar sign on top
of the hospital
exactly and this doctor might as well be
just taking wads of cash honestly i
think if you you can probably create
your own law firm that just
targets their patients because you'd be
very well-off both step infections are
very common they happen all the time
is that your professional opinion it is
i see and in your professional opinion
is it also common for a post-op
infection to result in a
double amputation does that happen all
the time too you don't know what she's
going to say right there she might say
yes in a situation like this where this
went wrong his heart
blew up he had a lung problem yeah
that's exactly what i would expect to
see and these doctors did a fantastic
job that's
completely impeccable what would he have
done in that case thank you your honor i
remember the questions
why didn't you page me sooner we just
heard the murmur this morning this
morning
yeah look at this growth you knew he was
a heart patient this didn't concern you
of course it did that's why you're here
so what do we do the infection is eating
away at his graft so not only is he
having a fever because his
joint is infected which she knew somehow
without doing any diagnosis
but his heart valve also has an
infection on it vegetation means it has
actual bacterial growth on it
and she's only performing the surgery on
his leg but not on the heart dr taurus
you need to see this i was changing his
compression socks and i saw this his
leg's gray
cold i can't find a pulse why aren't you
checking all the time exactly so when a
patient is laying in a hospital
they're not just passively laying there
the reason they're in the hospital is
because there are wound checks every few
hours neuro checks
the residents come in around on the
patient every morning look at the wound
look at the leg
and it seems like some area where
there's already been some problems
you probably don't want to hide them
behind compression socks
exactly okay where's whitney i told her
she had time to grab lunch before travis
woke up all right you need to go find
her and tell her that's an ultrasound
portable ultrasound machine that we use
to hear
blood flow and the reality of it
you don't need that for his leg you can
see that it's not getting circulation
okay i've got to go in and do a number
to be on this oh no i have a problem
so an embolectomy like they're saying
that a blood clot has now traveled to
his arteries i can't i can't even
follow this there's nothing like there's
no medical sense
i mean doesn't that presume that a blood
clot has flown down to
his arterial system now in his
legs yeah which means it did a full
circle in his body just
i don't try this embolectomy he could
lose his legs well he can live without a
leg he can't live without a functioning
heart
if you do the heart tomorrow it gives
him an extra down antibiotics all right
he'll be more stable and the heart
surgery will be less risky christina
this is travis reid we're talking about
let me try to save his leg does the
course of treatment change if you're
dealing with a famous person uh it
doesn't change that but it does depend
on patient need like if a patient's
job is intimately tied to a specific
uh function of their body we will work
harder to save that
i see yeah so there is some truth to
that you may have seen like
musicians play their instruments during
brain surgery
because they want to make sure they
don't do any damage to something that's
really important
to that whoa that is cool yeah what's
his temper oh he was febrile over a
night but his white counts did
great
what's going on travis what aren't you
telling me what's wrong
full-on necrosis so here's the weird
stuff there are people checking on him
yeah
why is he the one pointing that out yeah
and why are they so casually strolling
in like in the middle of the day he's
basically throwing more clots
and the fact that they waited to do his
heart
it's obviously she's guilty yeah i'm
gonna just call him
this is a civil suit she's not guilty
she's liable and i think so is the
hospital here i agree
and notice where his uh necrosis was
starting from
below the knee below the knee why do
they go above oh man
that's that's that's unfortunate if you
want to see the rest of our analysis
click here for part two on legal eagles
channel check out legal eagle